Russia collusion Trump oh man why did
you do you know so even the average
person that's kind of sitting there
saying oh my god the guy I voted for is
doing this you got to be kidding me
right Democrats obviously ran with it
you know all these guys so we have 100
evidence of what happened here and like
uh that wasn't right oh you guys just a
Durham report oh it's not a big deal
let's just move on you know you know the
dossier was paid for Hillary Clinton
let's just move on to the next stop so
and then so Obama was what Obama knew
all along what they were investigating
Trump yeah but you know what everybody
knows because he's the president and the
Mar-A-Lago let's go do this yeah because
he has these documents so you know
January 6 look what he did it's terrible
to more and more and more they try to
spin this
and and then it comes out two three
years later as being bad The credibility
keeps taking a hit to the point where
now they're talking about you know
people are running for president talking
about getting rid of the FBI because
it's messing up uh the nation and
dividing us right